cette vidéo est faite en partenariat
avec une marque de vpn dont vous avez
peut-être entendu par les normes et pn
vous donnerait plus de détails
un peu plus loin dans la vidéo bonjour à
toutes et à tous bienvenue pour une
vidéo que je ne pensais vraiment pas
faire sur cette chaîne
mais on apparaît dans la dernière vidéo
vous me l'avez demandé en commentaire et
en fait je crois que les vidéos wat in
my phone c'est un petit peu un guilty
pleasure quand on dit un plaisir
coupable
c'est à dire que je crois que j'ai
toujours voulu en faire mais j'ai
toujours trouvé ça genre c'est pas hyper
léger pas assez bien entraîné mais
peut-être pas assez travaillé pas assez
écrit et je me suis dit vas-y mec rate
de toute la pression peut aussi faire
des vidéos un peu plus des tentes doit
pas manger bleu provence 24 heures mais
dire ce qu'il ya dans ton téléphone ça
peut ça peut être intéressant et ça peut
intéresser des gens donc voilà bienvenue
sur aube watt's in my phone edition 2020
alors donc là vous voyez on est en
couleurs même si mon écran et en noir et
blanc
la retransmission donc l'enregistrement
lui et en couleurs donc le noir et blanc
est vraiment juste un filtre si vous
prenez une photo en dans votre mode noir
et blanc la photo est en couleur ambre
est donc là de façon j'ai enlevé noir et
blanc pour voir mieux voir les
applications puisque je vous les montre
mais en temps normal donc ça en noir et
blanc
la première page comme je vous
l'expliquais dans ma dernière vidéo ce
n'est que les outils on a photo alors
photo j'utilise plus google photos
pendant longtemps j'ai utilisé google
photo besoin que d'une manière générale
en fait j'essaie de sortir le plus
possible des produits google pour des
raisons de vie privée en fait quand j'ai
fait ma vidéo on a tous quelque chose à
cacher ça m'a vraiment fait prendre
conscience de pas mal de trucs et je
fais beaucoup plus confiance à apple
qu'à google sur toutes les questions de
vie privée parce qu'ils exploitent les
données différemment et qui sont
vraiment axé sur ce truc de privacy en
tout cas beaucoup plus que google c'est
pas parfait évidemment mais c'est un bon
compromis pour moi aujourd'hui je
reviens de faire le montage et je
m'arrête sur cette séquence
en fait je voulais juste éclaircir le
fait que effectivement apple en termes
de vie privée
c'est loin d'être parfait et au passage
on pourrait croire que
fustige google alors que je trouve que
c'est une boîte qui fait aussi des trucs
formidables notamment youtube par
exemple en fait je pense que ce dont
j'aurais dû parler dans cette vidéo et
que j'ai oublié c'est cet arbitrage en
tête entre la vie pratique et la vie
privée si la vie privée c'était
extrêmement important pour moi et
c'était vraiment le truc le plus en
tentant et ben y'a plein d'applis vous
allez voir que j'utiliserai pas quoi
dire que j'utiliserai pas un iphone en
fait mais là ce curseur entre vie
pratique c'est à dire c'est à dire à
quel point les choses sont simples
efficaces je me prends pas la tête et c
est la vie privée voilà je vais juste
parler de ça et d'ailleurs
noordpeene je voulais en parler au
milieu de la vidéo mais en fait je pense
que c'est le meilleur moment pour en
parler ça maintenant donc je vous en
parle tout de suite
alors je vais être totalement
transparent avec vous ça fait plusieurs
mois et voir années que vous avez vu pas
mal de mes comparses parler de vpn j'ai
moi même été sollicitée par plusieurs
marques de vpn différente si bien qu'à
un moment je me suis dit bon mais en
fait c'est quoi je vais prendre une
matinée et jeu tous les tester et c'est
ce que j'ai fait c'était il ya quelques
mois déjà c'était quand j'ai donné cette
vidéo en fait j'ai dû rester dans un tel
quelques semaines et vu que la connexion
était publique je me dis que c'est le
bon moment pour le faire et je vous jure
très honnêtement ma meilleure expérience
et pour moi donc le meilleur chez denner
vpn de tout ce que j'ai testé un vpn
c'est un vieil choo private network donc
un réseau virtuel privé
à quoi ça sert à ça sert à des choses
plutôt simple par exemple à chiffrer vos
données lorsque vous utilisez le wifi
public
quand vous utilisez un oui du public
dans un hôtel ou dans un restaurant un
café enfin tout ça on peut très
facilement choper pas mal d'informations
qui transitent via le wifi un vpn vous
protège de ça donc ça c'est l' usage
principal que j'en fais moi
personnellement et un autre usage qui
est cool c'est que ça vous permet
d'accéder à tous les contenus sur le web
sans être bloqués géographiquement
puisqu'en fait vous pouvez vous
connecter via n'importe quel pays en
fait avec le vpn vous allez choisir
voilà je veux me connecter depuis les
etats-unis depuis l'allemagne etc etc
et donc c'est très pratique sur un site
comme netflix parce que du coup vous
pouvez accéder au catalogue qui est
normalement réservé aux américains
et aussi vous pouvez l'installer sur
tous vos appareils c'est-à-dire
ordinateurs tablettes téléphones tout ça
est oublié bénéficier d'une offre
incroyable de -70% ouais ouais ouais
vous a bien fondu -70% sur north vpn
points comme cela chez russe torse
encore une fois pour les avoir essayé
cotisez nord et peine régulièrement je
vous le recommande sincèrement et
maintenant on peut continuer cette vidéo
mais truc sur lequel j'arrive pas à me
passer de google clairement par exemple
leur agenda
c'est un agenda qui démonte et dès que
j'ai un nouveau projet je crains agents
d'adp dédiés par exemple sur le meilleur
podcast
on a un agenda spéciale le meilleur
podcast pour mettre les invités etc
j'ai essayé des applis tierces et
d'agenda généralement je reviens
toujours à google agenda au bout d'un
moment il ya peu de fonctionnalités
qu'il me faudrait et qui a pas dans
google agenda horloge c'est bien mais
l'utilisé pas comment la veille
vous même vous savez pourquoi si tim a
peur pour moi donc si vous vivez dans
une grande ville si vous vivez dans
l'une de ces villes là en france il ya
que paris et lyon clairement city ma
peur c'est la meilleure appli de
déplacement par exemple super métro ça
te dit tu dois être à l'avant du wagon à
l'arrière extra pour choper les
meilleures correspondances point pour
elle plus vite possible
bref c'est c'est la meilleure appli et
ça prend en compte aussi d'autres
appliquent donc dedans il ya les vtc
mais il ya aussi les vélos le vélib ce
genre de trucs et parfois même je sais
plus si le fait encore mais des fois il
te fait des trajets hybride genre il te
dit par exemple on te conseille de
prendre le btc jusque là là il ya une
borne vélib
tu prends le vélib jusque là enfin bref
c'est ça de la bad j'ai rejoint le club
c'est une des applis qui était gratuite
mais que j'ai décidé de contribuer en
payant parce que voilà je trouve que
quand le travail est bien fait c'est
important de rétribuer aussi les
développeurs et d'ailleurs trucs
intéressants ils ont créé le 6 et my
city mapper mobility index là on voit le
confinement ou paris ne bougeait plus
grâce à leurs données en fait ils ont le
déplacement des parisiens tout cas des
parisiens qui utilisent l'appli
j'imagine et donc on voit comme à partir
du confinement vraiment on était à 5 % à
peu près de la mobilité d'habitude
et là on est en train de remonter petit
à petit et ça se ferait progressivement
globalement là on se rend compte que
paris est vraiment dans toutes les
villes qu'ils ont dans
les quatre villes les moins confiné n'y
a pas de confinement mais veut dire dans
les quatre villes où il ya le plus de
déplacements
google maps j'utilise surtout pour des
bonnes adresses que je note voilà c'est
des petits restos que j'aime bien ou des
restos que j'ai envie de visiter mais
par contre j'ai pas mal géolocalisation
elle a été désactivé toujours la même
logique de vie privée par rapport à
google
alors est-ce que c'est logique de faire
plus confiance à city ma peur qu'à
google maps je sais pas honnêtement je
n'ai pas les arguments pour répondre à
cette question mais je me sens plus à
l'aise en train comme ça coût de notes
alors ça c'est une api que j'ai sur mon
ipad aussi est en fait tous les matins
où la veille généralement je fais ma
tout doux donc comme je vous ai expliqué
dans cette vidéo l'a7 ou douche pas
retrouver ici
parfois c'est relou de sortir l'ipad
juste pour voir ce qui est sûr en tout
12 si j'ai besoin de justes de la
consulter page peut le faire ici très lo
c'est mon appli organisationnelle de
référence cependant pour ma chaîne
youtube et les différentes vidéos les
prochaines vidéos et tout alors je
montre vite fait comment ça marche
vous avez vous pouvez créer différents
panneaux et dans ces panneaux vous créer
des cartes donc là ses tableaux
d'exemple que vous pouvez enrichir avec
des photos avec ce que vous voulez moi
par exemple j'ai un tableau genre
prochaine vidéo j'ai un tableau
ressources à lire j'ai un tableau genre
comptabilité enfin voilà ce genre de
truc mais par exemple à certains projets
par exemple à céret une image une
histoire que j'avais passé plusieurs
vidéos elles doivent passer par
différents processus par exemple
l'écriture le tournage le montage le
mixage l'étalonnage et c'est donc pour
chacune de ces étapes va y avoir une
colonne et donc je vais déplacer chaque
carte donc chaque vidéo en fonction de
là où elle en est dans le processus de
pardon une fois que pour l'épisode 3 le
tournage effet paf on passe au montage
et donc je sais où j'en suis surtout mon
projet c'est hyper bien fait freedom
c'est un bloqueur d'applications en gros
vous mettez une session par exemple 20
minutes quand vous la commencer ça
bloque l'accès à plein d'applications
dont vous avez défini et aussi plein de
sites internet donc c'est super utile
quand on veut se concentrer sur un truc
je le recommande dans cette logique
vraiment de se décrocher son téléphone
mannheimer c'est mon timer de méditation
donc ça fait le taff ça fait ce qu'on
lui demande c'est simple simple d'usagé
donc c'est parfait pas la méditation
guidée par contre c'est un bon c'est
juste un timer glynn kyste c'est des
résumés de bouquins alors un résumé de
bouquins s'est jamais comme un bouquin
mais ça peut donner des pistes de
réflexion sur certains trucs ça peut
donner envie de lire un bouquin et ils
ont aussi des versions audio donc
alors tout est en anglais mais si vous
êtes à l'aise avec l'anglais c'est très
pratique par exemple pour courir je
l'utilisent de temps en temps dans les
livres que j'ai ouvert par exemple
c'était irrésistible de adama leur dont
je me suis servi pour faire la dernière
vidéo c'est assez cool mais le danger
c'est penser que en lisant le blink on a
lu le bouquin c'est une appli payante de
linksys mais il me semble qu'avec la
version gratuite en ce cas à l'époque où
j'avais la version gratuite
il proposait un bling par jour ce qui
est pas mal non plus parce que vu qu'on
sait que le blink va disparaître mais en
fait on est pas mal tenté de le lire
avant qu'il disparaisse quoi surtout
qu'il me semble que la version payante
n'est pas donné forest alors ça c'est
une appli hyper cool est importante
quand on voulait pas toucher à vos
téléphones mais entend moins drastiques
que freedom
vous définissez un un temps par exemple
dix minutes cliquez sur planté donc là
pendant ce temps là en fait il ya un
arbre virtuel évidemment qui est en
train de se planter
ok et donc si vous sortez de l'apli
voilà et vous dis cliquez ici pour
revenir à forest immédiatement pour
empêcher la mort de l'arbre c'est une
game ification pour rester le plus
possible sur cet écran là en fait et
donc ne pas être sur des applis ne pas
être en train de se coller sur votre
futur instagram etc j'avoue que
j'utilise pas tant que ça j'utilisais à
une période mais en fait maintenant
quand j'ai besoin de me concentrer sur
un truc juge mais le téléphone loin
j'utilise quand j'ai pas le choix par
exemple je suis dans un café là mon
téléphone est forcément à côté de moi du
coup c'est la justice foirest et fit
c'est une appli à la fois de sport et de
recettes que j'utilisais un moment que
j'ai repris la récemment en faisant
cette vidéo je me dis qu'il faut que je
me remette en fait il ya des appliques
qui sont sur mon téléphone qui sont plus
là en mode la personne que j'aimerais
être utiliserait cette appli tous les
jours et donc c'est plus un rappel de
dans quelle direction j'ai envie d'aller
et fit clairement c'est là parce que
j'ai envie de l'utiliser et 120 pages
qu'on me rappeler que c'est un objectif
en plus c'est un abonnement payant et
c'est donc un engagement financier tout
il faut pas non plus tomber dans le
revers de sa donc faut pas culpabiliser
de ne pas l'utiliser mais sûr c'est
important de le garder un an rappelle
d'ailleurs noter que mon fond d'écran et
noir et blanc ce qui fait qu en fait
quand je passe en noir et blanc ça ne
change absolument rien la barre du bas
j'aime me rappeler que c'est un
téléphone malgré tout donc il ya le
téléphone et sms comme navigateur
j'utilise safari
pour la même raison que chrome google
etc donc safari ils ont mis un peu plus
d'accent sur la vie privée et c est un
truc que j'aime bien sûr ça paraisse que
très facilement
paf je peux avoir un lecteur qui me
permet de lire un article sans être gêné
par de la pub etc
voilà je suis un très pratique et pour
douter la musique j'utilise apple
musique
ce que j'apprécie c'est toutes les
playlists faites par les curateurs et
les curatrice qui sont un peu experts
dans leur domaine
donc ça défonce ailleurs soulevé me
suivre ses sirius north sur apple
musique vous aurez par exemple ma
playlist quand je cuisine avec des
petits sont aux petits oignons blue va y
passe quand vous êtes triste atouts get
ahead to increase de tempel jeu j'ai
vraiment écrit ça la deuxième page
là on est sur gmail donc mon application
de mails whatsapp j'utilise parce que
les gens utilisent voix de sape mais en
vrai je préfère utiliser signal signal
s'ils n'appliquent conversation mais qui
est beaucoup plus privé beaucoup plus en
crypté watts appartient facebook signal
n'appartient pas à facebook final c'est
aussi une appli qui est recommandé par
edouard snowdon on qui même si je
comprends pas tous les ans cryptage
extra mais je fais confiance à snow
donne donc bon je suis même les
influenceurs sont influencés ce qui est
cool c'est que j'ai réussi à convaincre
certaines personnes d'aller sur signale
donc en fait mes contacts les plus
proches on va dire ceux avec qui je
communique le plus sont sur signal et
donc c'est mieux mais le chimp donc ça
c'est l'outil que j'utilise pour envoyer
ma newsletter parce que j'ai news les
tâches pas si vous êtes au courant
www.sonos.com vont entrer votre adresse
mail
j'utilise très peu en ce moment là la
newsletter que j'ai fait je pensais
quand j'ai passé les quatre cent mille
abonnés pokey de caste c'est une appli
qui est à la fois sur ios et android
c'est limpide podcast donc
il ya bientôt il ya notamment le
meilleur podcast qui est vraiment un
podcast incroyable les trucs que
j'apprécie c'est notamment le fait par
exemple de couper les silences donc ils
coupent automatiquement les silences ça
m'a fait économiser 1h25 depuis que
j'utilise cette fonctionnalité j'écoute
assez peu de podcasts en vrai en fait
j'écoute surtout quand je fais du sport
et je fais pas énormément blanc très bon
podcast audio photo et vidéo dj argos et
l'appli deux mondes rhône
ce parc caméra je trouve c'est une super
caméra pour faire des story instagram
par exemple voilà pour enregistrer j'ai
juste après c'est appuyer sur l'écran ok
donc là je prends une séquence ensuite
je passe en mode self i je suis noter qu
ans et je peux éviter le début la fin
comme je veux ajouter une transition etc
et donc du coup dynamiser un peu mais
story renard cependant stabilisateur
c'est un salvateur avec lequel j'ai fait
ce genre de plan par exemple fini
procine appli qui permet d'aller
beaucoup plus loin dans l'utilisation de
la caméra de l'iphone c'est souvent trop
complexes pour ce dont j'ai besoin et
foals et made c'est pour faire des
citoyens instagram un peu plus léché et
donc ça m'a permis de faire ce genre de
story par exemple je trouvais canon
glitch et c'est un peu comme une folle
d'emails dans le sens où ça me permet de
créer un truc que je verrai utilisé dans
une soirée par une fois une photo et
genre par exemple je peux la glitch et
je peux faire des trucs un peu voilà un
peu un peu chelou pssa stylet et après
je peux en faire un gif par exemple sa
position 1 position de 10 jeux mais n'a
par exemple snap side c'est mon logiciel
de retouche photo qui je trouve est une
brute il me semble que c'est un logiciel
de google mais je passe sur les applis
nike pour faire du sport que je trouve
son excellente sens critique c'est mon
appli pour noter les films et les séries
et ss detector ça c'est pour voir quand
est-ce que l' iss donc la station
spatiale internationale va passer au
dessus de chez vous ou en tout cas quand
est ce que lee et 16 sera
potentiellement visibles dans le ciel
et donc ça a permis
voir par exemple il ya quelques quelques
semaines devant l iss c'était assez
incroyable comme expérience
cam scanner pour scanner des documents
j'ai un scanner franchement je n'utilise
pas je dise comme si l on a un premier
dossier démon c'est les trucs ou
vraiment c'est que c'est pas très bien
code de la route pour me rappeler qu'il
faut je passe mon permis et c'était donc
la page 2 et la page 3 un évent que sur
du dossier on n'est sûr
quand je pars en voyage maison c'est
tous mes trucs de domotique s'aimer
lumière connecté à mon fournisseur
d'électricité c'est ma livebox
c'est mon aspirateur robot essais et
fttx 10 dnd à naples hyper simple qui
permet de coder des choses en gros vous
allez dire si vous avez des lumières
connectez vous allez dire si je reçois
un mail de telles personnes fait
clignoter mes lumières en rouge
je dis n'importe quoi utilitaire c'est
un peu mon fourre tout que j'utilise
très peu mais que c'est important que
j'aie au cas où par exemple google photo
ba je le mets là parce que je vais pas
dans l'appli mais parfois on en voit un
lien google photos et donc il faut avoir
l'appli google photos pour l'ouvrir et
enfin un dossier paraît ce que j'utilise
plus d'ailleurs depuis je n'ai pas
utilisé depuis début du confinement donc
j'ai assez fier de moi c'est pas ouf
quand joue ce dossier c'est pas ouf
mais bon ça fait longtemps que j'ai
ouvert donc je suis très content voilà
je me rend aussi compte que j'ai pas
tourné dao trop pourquoi ils virent
chelou donc voilà donc j'espère que ça
vous a plu
la prochaine vidéo sera un peu moins
légère et je suis en live là tout de
suite sur twitch twitch point tv ce
logiciel torse
on va un petit peu paraître la vidéo et
après on va jouer à walden j'ai vu qu'un
jeu qui s'appelle walden donc par
rapport à ma vidéo sur la solitude je
trouve ça va je me dis ça peut être cool
de jouer ensemble
voilà donc eh bien tout de suite
j'espère gros bisous et sinon adam
une deux semaines à une main love peace
ciao